hi everyone Matt Luigi here with an
Elden ring video a bit different than my
usual in case you missed it there's been
some discussion going on surrounding
Elden ring and the game awards Elden
ring has been nominated for quite a few
Awards including best narrative which
has caused a bit of Fallout from people
incredulous about the nomination saying
Elden ring has no story or one much
worse than other nominees like God of
War Ragnarok then there are others
incredulous at those people saying Eldon
ring has a great unique narrative that
just isn't spoon fed to the player now
because I'm a lorehead who delves deep
into the stories in Elden ring and
because Eldon Rings DLC announcement
could very well take place at the game
awards maybe hopefully I wanted to spend
a little time talking about The
Narrative of Elden ring and my thoughts
on the whole matter as we get started
feel free to subscribe if you aren't
already as that oddly includes most of
you who are returning viewers and with
that enjoy and before we get into the
thick of it it seems to me that this
discussion is just a symptom of a larger
conversation basically the game of the
year battle between between Elden ring
and God of War they both came out this
year so unfortunately they get compared
even though they are very different
games on the one hand God of War is a
generally linear action-adventure game
with a straightforward narrative
featuring a father figure often
protecting his son it also has a set
small number of weapons that you upgrade
skills for on the other hand Eldon ring
is not any of that but funnily enough
that description fits like a glove onto
from software's previous action game
sekiro literally everything I said from
weapon skills to narrative applies to
sekido making it a much better game to
talk about in conversation with god of
war but that's not how we do things as a
society so let's get into Alden Ring
versus God of War and see what's missing
from the narrative discourse to start I
think I'm in a good position to make
this video for one I obviously have a
pedigree of investment and appreciation
from software's approach to storytelling
I have a dark souls 3 video all about
how the placement of just one item tells
a story and provides context for the
area and the world a really good piece
of environmental storytelling that from
software is really big on in their
Narrative Approach and I have an Elden
ring video all about the themes of
struggle and perseverance that the game
really emphasizes both in story and in
gameplay reifying that story so I am one
who can see the Merit in the narrative
aspects of the game but at the same time
I think I may fall into a different boat
than a lot of the other Elden ring
creators defending the game obviously
they have a similar appreciation for the
game's storytelling but I think from
what I've seen that they haven't been
adequately responding to the issues
people have with the nomination I
basically think that they're giving
Eldon ring too much credit when it
should be criticized or at least
acknowledged to have a pretty mediocre
at best active story or plot and not to
say that there aren't toxic people
claiming Eldon ring has no narrative
Merit they are obviously wrong but so
too are Elden ring stands that are
deriding other games unconstructively
saying things like a cutscene fueled
story which is the traditional way of
Storytelling in video games is basically
more of a movie than a game I didn't
know we were saying Metal Gear games
aren't games anymore so the game awards
defines the criteria for the best
narrative award as the following for
outstanding storytelling and narrative
development in a game people are upset
that Elden ring is in the running versus
a game like God of War Ragnarok which
has much more clearer straightforward
storytelling and narrative development
now I actually think Eldon ring has
fantastic storytelling but its narrative
development like most from software
games is pretty mediocre in my opinion
we could bicker a bit about what
narrative development means and argue
Elden Rings cryptic piecemeal
storytelling counts as a form of
narrative but I think we'll have a
better discussion if we can agree to
just talk about the main present
narrative or story of the game basically
this would exclude the storytelling
found in Elden Ring's lore which anybody
watching my channel will probably agree
is done really well but that's not what
I think the core issue is in this
discussion many players go through Elden
ring or the soul series not really
knowing what they're doing plot wise the
same isn't true for God of War whatever
that discrepancy is is what I want to
talk about in this video
there is plenty to piece together in
Elden ring there are complex factions
and characters with buried motivations
that you can learn intimate details
about but in my experience that is
almost wholly confined to the lore the
actual story or Narrative of the game as
you play it the story of your tarnished
is a lacking one yes your character is a
blank slate to allow for character RPG
expression but the game doesn't let you
express that outside of your combat
playstyle your interactions with NPCs or
even lots of the world is not impacted
at all and this leads the game's story
progression to be pretty Hollow you are
simply that which kills the big bads and
maybe occasionally helps out an NPC with
their one Quest compare this to another
blank slate RPG IP The Fallout Series
where you have the same blank slate but
your RPG Investments and choices impact
your relationships with NPCs the kind of
person you are and how you can Traverse
the world the story elements are
adaptive to your role playing and there
are still substantive narrative
developments I also take issue with the
games and PCs many of these characters
have developed backstories like Ronnie
like and EG but their presence as
characters with significant development
or arcs is Bare Bones and lacking in the
present game as you play through it like
what is the character development of
Ronnie through the game or even Melina
do they change that much throughout the
Story from beginning to end do you see
their progression Melina and even
torrent would have been great cases to
have been more involved and had more
progression as characters since they are
always by our sides we could see them
grow and change and develop as we grow
through the world there is a tiny bit of
this with Melina disappearing coming
back and talking about her Newfound
resolve but that basically just puts her
in the same position as she was at the
start of the game yes there is some lore
contextual development but the actual
experience of the character in the story
is basically the same that progression
for either of them and a lot of the rest
of the cast simply isn't there and yeah
there are some cases of change like with
Bach or Eureka but these again are just
not that much box progression and
complexity as a character pale in
comparison to a lot of the characters in
God of War like freyas most of the main
characters in God of War feel much more
deeply developed by the game than those
in Eldon ring and that really isn't that
surprising when there's a lot more time
spent with them and they have a lot more
instances of dialogue there's roderica
who is a reference to farnes in berserk
but farnese has a hugely more developed
character Arc sure berserks a
decades-old manga but I'm just trying to
make the point that if we judge The
Narrative of Elden ring fairly not
handicapping it at all because it's just
a video game holding it to the same
standard as we would any other work of
art I think the active Narrative of
Alden ring is lacking the game world as
I play through it that's the important
part does not have very complex
developing characters nor a very
compelling plot like hayata has a cool
story and Quest but it really just isn't
that developed there isn't enough there
or time spent with her or interactions
or dialogue or actions on her part they
make for a developed character like we
see in any other kind of medium if we
saw hayata's story in another medium I
don't think she would come across as a
very developed or interesting character
because there isn't enough there I think
that's the case for a lot of people
myself often included for Elden ring now
of course the game does have some
narrative beats you find your maiden
dead you team up with Melina you get to
the Earth tree get rejected burn it all
down and defeat the boss Gauntlet at the
end but these don't feel like a fleshed
out story or Journey for the player
there isn't a ton of narrative
development going on throughout now this
is obviously kind of the point with the
style of game fromsoft is making insert
quote everybody's heard about Miyazaki
reading English novels as a kid not
understanding part of it and wanting to
make us feel the same way playing these
games
sekiro did not have these same story
issues to such a degree but it also had
a lack of the kind of lore so many
people myself included really love an
Eldon ring and other similar titles
overall I don't think this design
approach is worse though I do think the
game would benefit from a stronger more
developed story and more dynamic
characters after all those novels
miyazakirad had fully developed stories
and characters we always come to the
characters and bosses in these games
almost as relics we read of their past
accomplishments and Feats but the story
almost always feels basically over by
the time we arrive again I get that this
is partially the point but a little bit
of Leaning into allowing the player to
be more a part of that story just
sometimes would be something I would
find enjoyable basically if we the
players are like Miyazaki reading those
English novels give us just a little bit
better understanding of the language
instead of being an A1 or an A2 speaker
maybe sometimes let us be a B1 or a B2
speaker I don't want Elden ring or
future from software titles to be just
like other mainstream releases with all
the plainly straightforward narratives I
appreciate the difference in difficulty
storytelling approach and overall game
experience but at the same time that
doesn't mean I have to avoid all
criticism especially of something that
might seem core to that approach I think
Elden Ring's story is pretty lackluster
but I don't think that it has to be to
keep most or even all of the core
features that demarcate the game as a
special experience it's easy to say that
the game has a problem with boss reuse
but it's harder to genuinely say it has
a problem with narrative especially
because there are so many others saying
that who simply don't enjoy the overall
game philosophy and are just using this
as an excuse to attack the game I don't
want to change that philosophy I just
want a better story and those two things
are not mutually exclusive all that said
I am happy with the nomination at the
game awards I think Elden ring showcases
fantastic storytelling does mostly for
stuff that happened before we start
playing in the game world we do get to
experience the learning of that
information as players so it is very
much still in-game storytelling just of
a different kind and another YouTuber
the lore Hunter actually has a great
video just released on the idea of
finding the information and story as the
player you should really go check it out
if any of this video has been
interesting at all so I'm excited to see
what people think and how Elven ring and
God of War do at the awards in total I
haven't beaten God of War but from what
I've played I think Elden ring is still
the better game in my opinion I know
quite a surprise coming from the Elden
ring YouTuber God of War is fun but I
don't think it does enough with its
gameplay and it really seems to segment
gameplay and story as two separate
things which is not something I super
like have cutscenes sure but some of the
segments just seem to go a bit far from
me I may be streaming the game awards if
I can get my Internet to play nice but
either way I will be making a video if a
DLC announcement comes out I hope you
have enjoyed this video and if you have
any thoughts on the subject please leave
them in the comments I don't think I'll
have another video out before
Thanksgiving so Happy Thanksgiving to
everyone and if you don't celebrate that
specific holiday I wish you a happy
Happy fall harvest season and
celebration of some sort thanks so much
for watching feel free to join my
Discord in the description below and
I'll see you in the next video peace